there's a new premier English style Tea
House in Las Vegas but the space is
about more than just a place to get
swedes the Cobblestone Cottage is a
place that many
can go to and they wear many hats in
addition to getting tea and treats
customers will be able to see unique
pieces collected over the years they'll
also be able to attend themed events and
networking events the business is also
giving back to the Youth of our
community
we are opening up also an extension to
the Cobblestone cottage which will be
the Cobblestone Village and we will be
hiring youth with disadvantages
youth aging out of foster care we want
to help them with life skills teaching
them cooking classes financing we have
mentorship programs
right now reservation only for afternoon
tea but lunch is open for all and back
tonight's going to be the big grand
opening we have all those details posted
at 8newsnow.com